and finally new rule in order to
simplify things the RNC must just tell
us which Republicans aren't running for
president yes the field is more crowded
at an earlier time than ever because
each of these corporate ass liquors
wants to sign up mega rich donors like
Sheldon Adelson before one of the other
guys in the pack blows him first so
tonight as a service to billionaires who
want to know which one of these gems to
write the check to I've put together
this helpful 2016 billionaire buyer's
guide for the oligarch who wants to make
an informed choice so there we go let's
count it down the candidates according
to their current standing in the polls
starting at the bottom with Rick Baer on
the upside Rick wears glasses now so I
guess he's not stupid anymore on the
downside he's an Evangelic old Texas
[ __ ] kicker with limited intellect and
when has that ever led us astray
in eighth place is Marco Rubio his
strengths include fundraising and
reaching for a bottle of water without
anyone noticing but on the downside most
Americans think he's that kid Janet Reno
sent back to Cuba next is Ted Cruz tez
is born in Canada but don't let that
fool you he's a real [ __ ] and a big
fan of the Keystone oil pipeline because
he also used down from Canada Tech to
Texas where he grew up to be the
scariest Hispanic to come out of that
state since Javier Bardem and no country
for old men on the upside oh there's no
upside to take homes he's what you'd get
if Ayn Rand had half a sex change and
moved to Waco
in six places Rand Paul who has some
really good ideas like reduce drug
sentences and allowing ex-cons to vote
but also some crazy ones
he's like a Swiss Army knife where half
the blades are useful and half her
q-tips and AIDS needles what I really
like about Rand Paul is he's a true
maverick while most guys with the toupee
wanted to look like real hair
he styles his real hair to make it look
like a toothpick
Mike Huckabee you know it's the darndest
thing about Mike everyone says he's
likable but no one says they like him
Mike's a culture warrior who represents
conservatives who are still pretty sore
about Obama being black
unfortunately for Mike it looks like
most of his base has moved on and by
that I mean they're dead dr. ben Carson
is the Republicans black friend du jour
and although he although he's a
celebrated now retired brain surgeon he
believes that gay marriage caused the
fall of the Roman Empire that the
Affordable Health Care Act is quote the
worst thing that has happened to America
since slavery and that Obama may cancel
the 2016 election and declare martial
law Ben I know you don't practice
anymore but if you still have your brain
tools here's what I suggest
lie down put a mirror of your head so
you can see what you're doing and start
cutting because you're an insane
paranoid liar who will say absolutely
anything or as Fox News puts it when can
you start
coming in at number three in the polls
is New Jersey Governor Chris Christie on
the plus side people say Christie's more
authentic than the others and they like
him busy always goes with his gut
bakeries like him for the same reason
and talked about determination which
other candidate could have a doctor
operate on his stomach and tie it off so
that food could barely get in and still
find a way to stay fat as a house
yes it's Chris Christie one lap band
nothing I don't think he would do the
same thing to you in the primaries he
will chew you up and not spit you out
uh number two Jeb Bush whose strength of
course is that he's the smart Bush
downside well his brother left office
with an approval rating of twenty-two
percent whereas Bill Clinton went out
with a 68 percent approval so advantage
iller II there in terms of brand loyalty
Hillary's like if your last card was a
Camry and Jeb is like if your last car
was a clown shoot you out of a cannon
and the current number one choice among
likely Republican voters a man who needs
no introduction because he's been
stalking us the last eight years The
Unbearable Lightness of being
MIT Romney now on the plus side mit
wants to be President like your dog
wants that half a slim jim you drop down
inside the pack on the downside mit
speeches are so boring
Bill Cosby uses them to knock out
aspiring so good luck billionaires it's
an embarrassment of riches all right
that's our show